以及呃跟它相关的跟签名
还有pipeline day
就是因为C的的参数
是跟那个跟签名是息息相关的
就是怎么把CD的那个参数同步拿出来
去创建那个papi day或者是更签名
这个流程好
我们从SHADER的创建开始哈
我们先从它的主要主体流程
那么首先呢C的它有一个global seor map
它的这是一个全局变量
他们就管理着所有的seed的信息好
那么在成整个引擎一开始初始化的时候呢
它就会掉这个comply global smap的函数哈
当然了
它其实里面有两种模式
我们先跳进里面
具体的实现我们直接跳到真正的实现
在这个真正的实现这个compleglobal server map里面呢
呃它在往下有一个对
在最后面这里有个依附条件
就是如果配置了一开始就是配置了这个变量
那么它就会在这引擎一开始初始化的时候
就会创建所有的当前平台的C的就是调查
如果如果没有配置呢
那么默认呢一般是延迟
就是它不会进入这里来
那么他就是C的呢就是用到的时候才去create
就比如说你渲染命令或者是什么东西啊
需要用到某个C的
你去get那个seed的时候
他发现get不到
他才会去创建那个C的
而这里呢就是一下子就全部创建了
那它其实呢就是通过层层的流程
我们一步步跟进去
它其实就是最终就是这G
就是如果平时你用的时候
你就直接get就可以了
他如果有他就就已经创建了
他就直接返回
如果没有
那他就会去创建
那他这个呢实际上就是相当于是for循环一下
把所有的都get1遍
就会触发它的创建好
它里面的流程呢其实一步步到最里面
就是掉我们之前看过的那个RHII的
那个可能C的
那比如说这里面继续跳进去
那继续好走到这里呃
它下面
那就是这一步就会根据注册到的seed的信息
它是哪个类型
然后就会掉RHRI的GREY的啊
或者是安
那其他的就是根据不同的类型
调不同的IHI的创建命令
那么这个hi创建命令
就会到真正的实现里面去实现
比如说D3D12的实现
那比如说是我们回顾一下
顺便回顾一下
比如说他就是照这个D三D12dynamic
hr里面的这个实现去创建好
那么创建的时候有一个变量哈
之前我们没有留意
我们补充一下
就是这个所有的SHADER哈
它比如说这个有一个都是继承了这个seed data的
这个C的data里面
前面我们讲它有一个很重要的就是它的code
就是代码
它还有另外一个今天我们关注的是这个变量
这个变量叫cpc resource count
就是使用到的资源的数量
它其实是什么
我们跳进去一看就知道了
它其实就是表达了这个SHADER着色器
它用到多少个sampler
多少个sir v
多少个constant buffer
多少个UVV就是把所有的这个用到的参数
使用到的那个参数数据统计出来多少个
因为为什么
因为我们注册那个跟签名的时候
就是需要去这个信息好
我们记住它呃
这个信息呢就是在create的时候提取出来的
那记记记住这个类叫cp resource count
那他就是在创建的时候
那
这里面还记得吧
我们前面讲过
在这个code里面附带着一个optional data
然后我们就可以直接通过这个COVID
把这个信息提取出来
然后保存到那个变量里面去
保存到变量里面去
好嗯那么还有一个很重要的问题
那到底这个信息是怎么来的呢
我们现在知道加CREAC的时候
会把这个数量嗯存储起来
而且是通过这个扣传进来的
这个code一一起放进来的
那么到底这个真正的数据从哪里来的呢
那就是在真正编译的时候转进来的好
那我们看一下编译的代码
那他应该是COMPLI
这个这个就是D3D的C的真正的comply哈
这个DXC呢
是好像是5.1以上的版本才有的哈
不然就是FF开头的那个哈
那这个不重要
那么真正的编译代码就是在这里面
当然了
编译的代码涉及到很多复杂的东西
我们现在只关注一个东西
就是一个C的一个着色器
它用到的参数是怎么来的
这里呢就使用到了D差的一种啊
它的反射的技术呃
我们先找到那个往下找到那个一圈的函数啊
对
就是他其实其实当D叉去编译一段代码的时候
那么它整个编译出来的结果
是包含着所有的信息的
不只是说编译出一个可执行的代扣
它甚至它会存储着这一段着色器代码
所包含的所有的描述信息
那么这个是D差本身提供的功能哈
虽然我们平时写简单的demo的时候没有用到
都是手工填的
但是作为一个UE引擎
它面对各种各样非常复杂的这种信息呢
非常多的着色器呢
它就使用它
也就是说
他其实呃并不并不需要你额外去告诉他
只要你把正确的代码有了
它就可以去get出来
就是这个就是你你你编译完代码之后
你可以拿到这些
那就是ID3D开头的这些东西哈
那这些描述以及反射的信息
然后其实它的调用流程
大概就是你get到这个这个流这个东西
它会它可以seed里面
它有一个input by的一个DSC
你把它get出来
这个里面就存储着所有的变量的信息
然后把它解析出来就可以了
那比如说这里是一个for循环
for循环
找出他所有的这个每一个那个resource的信息
然后调用这个这个这个
这个已经是DX提供的那个接口了哈
就是调用它就拿到它的描述
这个描述
我们比如说我们看下面
那比如说它是一张贴图是吧
它就会记录着这张贴图的所有的信息
那这个就是我们这些变量啊
这些sir v的数量
就直接从它里面拿出来就可以了
直接从那个这个变量
这个变量就是那个DESC哈
直接是d e c get出来
就可以拿到所有的资源的那个信息
那我们现在关注的就是呃
像刚才那个什么SAMBER的数量啊
呃UVV的数量啊
就是这些
那就是这些变量
就是这是一个反射技术哈
就是稍微了解一下
我们可能不需要我们去改啊
我们知道这样字哈就可以了
那这是个模板类
就是你传进来的是D3
D12或者是第3D11啊
他都有的哈
那这个就是从这个反射的技术拿到这个数量
拿完这个数量
在编译的时候
它就会在下面把这一堆信息组装起来
那这个就是刚才我们那个cp resource
那就是把它组装起来
你看到没有
这些变量就是从反射里面拿出来的
然后组装起来
然后把它拼接到呃代码里面去
然后
生成
然后就拼出来了
那么这个最后拼拼接出来的那个code
就会传到那个i hi qua shader里面去
所以那边就拿到了这个数量的信息
OK好
那么创建CD的时候
就已经把每个C的
每一个C的的这个数量存储起来了哈好
那现在就到了什么
到了创建pipes day
可根签名
现在我们先看一下跟签名
根签名就是他我们直接看B站第12呢
这个呢就是封装了D3D12的那个跟签名
然后我们看它的构造函数啊
看它的构造函数
那它当然就包含包含着真正的跟签名啊
那我们看它的包装那个构造函数初始化
他在初始化的时候会你看会他会传出这个信息
这个信息呢就是这个C的里面的全部的信息包
就是一个一个流程里面
它对应的所有的C的全部的信息
就是因为你一个跟签名
你不仅仅一个C的嘛
你有顶点着色器
还有像素着色器
甚至还有各种各样的着色器
都会跟一个跟签名拼起来的嘛
那么那些信息是放在这里面的哈
注意这个注意这个结构化好
那么他其实就是会去用这个信息
去构建一个DCD
然后直接就初始化了
这个DSC就是几乎就已经是真正的那个DSC了
就是下面这里
那他已经构造出这个真正的DSC了
然后就用这个DSC来
拿到这个blob
然后就掉DX的device的这个qua
这已经是第三第12的最原始的那个API接口了
那么重点就是这个信息哈
注意哈那个这个类就是一个星期
我们去看一下它的构造函数
注意他哈
闯进来这个参数
这个传进来的参数
它就包含了所有的SHADER的信息
的参数的信息
那应该是一个
在
啊对在下面他会一个for循环
我们记得那个D3D12里面创建跟签名
就是首先要要要搞一个描述
要搞一个parameter是吧
那他就是根据这个传进来的参数搞一个for循环
然后每一个都会去创建一个这个
然后这个LUTPOLIMETER它有两种
在U1里面就是两种
要么就是这个script table
要么就是这个constant buffer cbb
然后这里面你看这个就是用到它的数量呃
是这样子的
因为一个信息里面它有多个SHADER
那比如说这个就是seed的resource
那么它就会创建这个descript lg
那它的类型就是就是我们最熟悉的D3
D12的这两个类型
那这个是PIAMETER
Tablost parameter
这个就是那个description l
然后去创建这一堆数量
然后计算它的参数的数量
最后这个描述符就用来真正的去创建
那个跟签名好
那这里还有一点不同的话
现在是这个东西哈
我们还要梳理清楚那个C的它是怎么构建出
就是我们刚才每一个C的输出
那个C的data里面的那个数量哈
是怎么构建这个呢
那我们看一下那个pipeline day就可以了哈
就是这个r h i green eight five
A glaphi
对是他们看这个
这个就是创建那个pipeline的时候呃
创建pipeline day
然后大概就会在
这里这里会创建一个
Sdday
OK我们看一下它
这里呢就就包含了一些信息
我们滚到下面去看啊
这直接看它的构造函数啊
它就是根据输入去构造一个这个CDDAY哈
然后有一个对
就是他看到没
这个bowser day
就是刚才创建跟签名用到的参数哈
那么现在就是用它来去构建这个东西哈
我们直接看这个函数
这个里面就会包含着所有的SHADER的信息
它你看它会顶点着色器max c的amplification
C的PIZC的
他会把每一个Z的
每一个就是整一个完整的信阳管线
所有的C的get出来
然后去构造那个信息
他在里面就是用这个set的data
因为我们记得哈
他虽然get出来的是一个那个vertex shader
对不对
但是VERTISEOR其实是继承了那个seed data的
就是每个人都是继承C的data的
所以呢他本质就是C的data
而C的data里面就是包含了这个这些信息对吧
这个信息这个信息就是就是我们刚才看的
所以呢在创建pipeline day的时候呢
实际上就是相当于是要把整个渲染管线用到的
每一个C的VXMASPXJS
把每一个C的他们的那个参数全部都统计出来
然后创建这个类型
这个叫BOWCDDAY
就是相当于是所有的CD加起来的
整个绑定的一条管线里面的
所有CD的面的信息
然后就是用它来创建更签名的
就是创建更签名的时候是是用到它的哈
这个
对创建更签名的时候是用这个参数
那么大体的流程呢其实就很简单啊
今天只是做一个补充
今天只是看一下基础的流程
就是第一啊
C的是在初始化的时候
一开始就创建的
然后那个seed里面的参数是怎么来的呢
是编译利用了D差的那个D3
D的那个反射的技术去获取出来
就是你当你去编译代码的时候
可以直接get到他相关的那个描述
然后再get到他所有的信息
包括就是每一个资源的
然后每个资源它比如说还有资源的名字啊
大小啊等等
全部信息都是可以拿到的
然后在那个时候就把一个seed所用到的
每个参数的数量封装成起来
拼接到那个内存里面去
然后就传到这个i h i g cc的阿SHAUC了
就会把这个信息存储在CD的成员变量里面
然后再创建这个跟签名的时候就会就会用到它
但是创建跟签名的不是对应
一个跟签名是对应多个SHADER
是整个流程所有的SHADER
所以呢他会把所有绑定的那个C的
就是顶点着色器
限速着色器
所有的信息先做一个统计
然后用来创建更签名
这样整一个渲染管线
所有的东西就创建完毕了
那么我们今天呢只是简单的做一个补充嘛
后面呢我们就可以开始有了这些基础
我们就可以开始真正的做我们的渲染命令
然后去构建一个pass
去炫耀我们炫耀的东西了
好今天就这么多